okay let's go next to our caller from
the 405 area code caller from 405 what's
your name where are you calling from
that's where I live this is John hey
John hey how you doing good good okay I
wrote different questions sorry I'm a
heavy breather so it's missing some but
okay here we go
um so you were talking like a lot the
past couple weeks about how it's really
important for us to give the way
president well whoever we is you know to
give the right president so that they
could nominee the court judge but in the
justice that we want and I have four of
us maybe a bad question here but just
against America try very good anyway so
I thought that since the politics plays
like a lot with the Supreme Court
justice being nominated by the president
is there like a no vote option that
anyone has ever considered with for
example and like it no harm no foul
scenario where the Supreme Court says
dudes with for jogging
it look like everything from city to
stay to present like well bogey at all
or lieu of the Supreme Court justice
position is that like a [ __ ] I don't
it's I mean it's just democracy John let
me interrupt for a second I don't know
what you're talking about and it sounds
like you're pressing I'm curious are you
doing something else in addition to
doing this call right now no I'm just
okay so I don't know if you're saying I
have no idea what you're saying you're
saying who doesn't get to vote and for
what in relation to the Supreme Court
okay I'm sorry
whatever judge is nominated by the
president yes could we have what I I got
myself away from the sound a little bit
so maybe that's better
um is there like a no though option like
a no harm no foul
what does that mean who vote what do you
mean no vote who get a court justice
themselves the the court justice votes
for themselves to get or not get out I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm man I'm doing this
all wrong okay so a president nominates
the court justice right and the court
justice obviously has a bias voting like
every single one of us so they're
nominated by the president that they're
applied with right yes so could there be
a no harm no foul like a no vote option
for court justice once they accept the
job it's not a quick descent the job
over no they have to get confirmed and
then who gets to vote no and for what
John I'm sorry I don't know what you're
talking about I'm gonna let you go I got
30 people holding here but I just I
don't know no harm no foul I don't know
what you mean I don't know what you mean